maintenant on politique le suspense a
duré beaucoup plus longtemps finalement
que prévu mais mélanie joly a finalement
remporté son pari on l'a su assez tard
ce soir dans la circonscription
d'ahuntsic cartierville
celle qui a terminé deuxième dans la
dernière course à la mairie de montréal
va donc tenter de se faire élire pour le
parti libéral justin trudeau et mathieu
mélanie joly a donc su rallier de toute
évidence une majorité des militants
malgré la controverse qui entouraient sa
candidature voilà que l'emporter ce soir
ici au collège andré grasset dans
l'arrondissement d'ahuntsic cartierville
et ça a pris du temps en effet ça a pris
et toute une journée en fait on a connu
le résultat vers 21h seulement c'est
qu'a eue loi tours au total dans le cas
de ce vote préférentiel comme quoi la
lutte a été serrée face aux trois autres
candidats qui affrontaient les candidats
bien connu ici dans la communauté
et voilà que c'est elle qui l'a emporté
ce soit et malgré ce scepticisme à son
égard parce que le parti libéral aurait
voulu selon certains favoriser sa
candidature par des manigances que le
parti libéral a toujours nié mais il y
avait ce scepticisme cette atmosphère
aujourd'hui qui régnait voilà que c'est
mélanie qu'il emporte dans son discours
alain indiqué ce n'est que le début ça
ne fait que commencer
vous savez moi je prends jamais rien
pour acquis
alors ce que jusqu'à l'investiture m'a
appris comme la candidate à la mairie
c'est l'importance la force de ses
convictions et la persévérance et c'est
exactement ce qu'on a fait tout notre
équipe mais aussi que tous les toutes
les équipes de tous les autres candidats
alors quelle a été la réaction de ses
adversaires et comment vont-ils se
rallièrent mélanie joly un appel au
ralliement c'est ce qu'on a entendu ce
soir de la part des autres candidats à
l'exception du candidat et likasi fia
qui a quitté les lieux en colère nous
dit-on mais voici la réaction des deux
autres on peut pas hésité tout le monde
le sache qui a eu du favoritisme
alors ça c'est normal mais en même temps
c'est la démocratie qui a parlé
ces légendes on sait qu'on a eu une
investiture et puis ces légendes 26
quartiers villes qui ont voté et puis
ils ont choisi madame joly et puis je
respecte ce choix
oui absolument je suis déçu mais surtout
mes membres mon équipe il est déçu mais
ça ça ne sera pas l'air évité si je te
dirai que je ne suis pas déçu mais être
déçu et ne pas se rallier à cette autre
chose et mélanie joly affrontera
notamment la candidate à député sortant
de maria mourani qui est maintenant dans
le camp des démocrates 19 octobre
merci mathieu mais c'est un homme
patient au revoir on appris aujourd'hui
bon maintenant de son côté six venant
que va a passé les prochains jours de sa
campagne au québec il était dans la
région de saint-hyacinthe cet après midi
une circonscription que les
conservateurs aimerait ravir au npd a
fait plus tôt le chef